nous sommes maintenant en compagnie de
l'invité de paris direct
[Musique]
bonjour raphaëlle branche merci de venir
jusqu'à nous vous êtes historienne
professeur à l'université spécialiste de
la guerre d'algérie à laquelle vous avez
consacré nombreux ouvrages d'articles et
vous signez vous cosigné avec raphaël
laurent de ski une série documentaire
dans laquelle vous donner la parole à
celles et ceux qui ont vécu la guerre
d'algérie en algérie mais aussi en
france ix en exil les accords d'evian
aujourd'hui 60 ans au delà de
l'anniversaire déjà de ce cessez-le-feu
puisque c'est son officielle doit partir
le projet le projet de série est parti
du désir de recueillir
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
la parole de ce qu'il avait vécu de ceux
et celles qu'il avait vécu c'était
vraiment ce projet de collecte
patrimoniale au départ et puis ensuite
de raconter avec la plus grande
diversité possible cette guerre dans ce
film on entend toutes sortes de
témoignages notamment de ceux qui qui
disent face caméra avoir tué et donnait
même des détails de la façon dont ils
ont et perpétré ces choses là ces crimes
la fin c'est la guerre le document
s'intitule en guerre pour l'algérie et
vous mettez un ace entre guillemets
aguer expliquer le sens de cette
précision qui n'a pas l'air que
morphologie non il s'agissait d'alerter
les téléspectateurs en leur disant voilà
il n'y a pas qu'une seule guerre pendant
cette guerre c'est un conflit multi du
multi directionnel les oppositions
internes aux algériens sont fortes les
oppositions internes aux français aussi
et au fil de la guerre on a plusieurs
guerres qui se déploie voilà c'était ça
notre lien il ya le fln oui les agrumes
des nationalistes sont pas tous les
mêmes tous les algériens ne sont pas
pour l'indépendance au départ et ce
genre de choses entre les français
également il ya l'ouest finalement arles
et vicky qui livrent à une guerre
fratricide
concept vous raconter les événements
dans l'ordre raphaëlle branche la
chronologie est détaillé avec minutie
tout commence un 1er novembre 1954 et ce
jour là elle n'attend pas et commis sauf
que personne ne sait que c'est la guerre
qui éclate en fait à ce moment là
plusieurs attentats y sont commis en
même temps sur le territoire algérien
alors aujourd'hui quand on dit attentat
on se représente peut-être pas
exactement de quoi il s'agissait c'est
essentiellement des atteintes aux biens
à l'époque est effectivement derrière il
y à l'action coordonnée d'un nouvel
acteur politique le front de libération
nationale qui signe son acte de
naissance dans cette cette coordination
mais à l'époque c'est un tout petit tout
petit groupe qui aurait très bien pu
être écrasé si si on avait compris la si
la france avait compris de quoi il
s'agit c'est à ce moment là parce que ce
1er novembre il ya un bus qui est arrêté
oui le premier intervenant du film un
certain brahim que vous avez opposé le
conducteur du bus en été extrêmement
heureux de pouvoir le retrouver qui nous
a raconté comment il a été arrêté par
une embuscade finalement on a fait
descendre du bus un certain nombre de
personnes et c'est un attentat pour le
courroux des gens meurent mais c'est
relativement rare encore à l'époque
effectivement dans les aurès qui vont
être la région une des régions les plus
les plus fortes de résistance dès le
début de la guerre et parmi les
personnes qui sont à bord du bus il ya
ce caïd oui et
c'est aussi le début de la fin en
quelque sorte d'une époque coloniale
raphaëlle branche c'est absolument comme
ça que j'aurais aimé appelé ce début le
début de la fin puisque effectivement
c'est la fin de l' empire français c'est
la fin du système colonial ce que les
acteurs français ignorent très largement
et pourtant et pourtant le monde a bien
changé depuis 1944 45 au moins lempire
france est en train de s'effondrer par
tous les empires coloniaux sont en train
de s'effondrer partout mais on a
l'impression que l'algérie c'est
différent
l'algérie ce sont des départements
français ya beaucoup de français une
colonisation de peuplement important et
il ya cette illusion que même si tout
s'effondre partout en algérie on va
réussir à pouvoir garde l'illusion que
l'algérie c'est la france alors que y as
tu meurs je dis seulement que vous
employez dans le film crimes délits -
iron ge qui ronge l'algérie c'est un
contexte d'ensemble
donc il ya deux de vos personnages qui
parlent de tumeurs et ça à voir
directement avec ce projet colonial qui
en est à sa fin tout le monde s'en rend
compte sauf la france alors beaucoup de
gens s'en rendent compte certains que
des illusions y compris les alliés de la
france aussi mais oui en fait ça nous a
paru très important de rappeler aux
téléspectateurs que ce n'est pas une
guerre comme on peut imaginer beaucoup
de guerre et notamment celle qu'on vit
en ce moment qui commence par une
agression la guerre d'algérie ce n'est
pas ça c'est à l'intérieur d'un
territoire qui est dit français depuis
plus d'un siècle et qui est et dont les
raisons les les origines de la guerre
c'est l'inégalité structurelle du
colonialisme et donc c'est de ça qu'il
fallait c'est ça qu'il fallait raconter
de la colonisation en tout cas la
manière dont elle a construit une
société à deux vitesses
en permanence et en interdisant
quasiment les passages possibles entre
entre le monde des colonisés et le monde
des colonisateurs et pour venir à bout
de ce qu'on appelle à l'époque les
événements d'algérie et prévoit encore
burger il ya un autre mot qui sera
utilisée c'est le mot de pacification et
oui pacification hameau typiquement
coloniale qu'on trouve dans d'autres
langues d'ailleurs qui sert à dire
qu'effectivement il s'agit simplement de
maintenir la paix de construire la paix
peu de gens en fait qu'ils disent
d'ailleurs vous savez il ya beaucoup
d'armes et qui me disent qu'ils sont
elles sont désormais d'agressions elles
sont toujours sur la défensive les armes
et donc la voilà on fait la guerre mais
en fait on dit qu'on fait la paix ça
fait partie des des manières de faire la
guerre en réalité un d'avoir ce genre de
vocabulaire fait misant donc oui c'est
le cas c'est le cas effectivement en
algérie qu'est ce qui vous a marqué en
réalisant ce travail qu'est ce que vous
avez découvert d'inédits alors d'inédits
moi puisque je suis historienne depuis
très longtemps et que j'interroge
beaucoup les gens peut être pas grand
chose en termes factuel en réalité ce
qui m'a beaucoup frappé c'est plutôt là
le ton le ton qu'on l'a certain nombre
de ces très vieilles personnes leur
leur capacité à revenir sur le passé
leur désir de transmettre très fort il
faut dire qu'on a réalisé ce travail en
plein qu'ovide en pleines difficultés de
circulation entre la france et l'algérie
et tous ces gens ont maintenu leur
engagement ont souhaité être là parce
qu'ils avaient le désir de transmettre
et ça ça m'a beaucoup touché ça a touché
beaucoup l'équipe et puis effectivement
certains et certaines sont allés très
loin dans le dans ce qu'ils ont livrée
et ça aussi c'est très très touchant et
c'est un beau cadeau et au fil des
échanges on retrouve finalement une
peut-être une sorte de bataille des
mémoires même si ce n'est pas exprimée
ainsi est ce cette bataille de mémoire
malgré ce que vous avez pu appeler à un
moment donné une injonction à l'oubli en
france pour ceux qui n'auraient pas
suivi qu'est ce que c'est que cette
injonction à l'oubli alors après la
guerre assurément en france en 1962 il
s'agit de tourner la page donc tous les
gens qui rappelle ce qui s'est passé à
savoir la guerre mais aussi la
colonisation et aussi l'échec du projet
colonial donc ça peut être les anciens
colonisés mais c'est surtout les
français rapatriés d'algérie ou les
harkis tous ces gens là sont sommés de
se taire et même les anciens appelés les
sols et l'eau un million cinq cent mille
soldats français qui sont partis faire
la guerre au titre de leur service
militaire sont sommés d'oublier et de
regarder devant et donc la france étant
dû à ce moment là vers l'avenir par
ailleurs dans un moment de de croissance
économique et de et de refonte politique
c'est la 5ème république qu'on est voilà
donc on est dans quelque chose qui
effectivement est assez dynamique et va
de l'avant mais va expliquer une forme
de refoulement qui à un moment va
revenir d'où la question qui se pose
comment cette mémoire se transmet tel
aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui on le voit elle passe
par effectivement toutes sortes de biais
les mémoires si on parle des mémoires 1
chaque mémoire collective ya un groupe a
une identité elle passe par plein de
vecteurs donc aujourd'hui en france en
tout cas les vecteurs sont multiples et
je pense notamment à la prolifération
des oeuvres de création qui sont
extrêmement nombreuses et qui sont des
formes de deux discours mémoriel mais il
y en a d'autres
/ et qu'en est il de l'accès aux
archives alors en france l'accès aux
archives est régi par la loi donc ça
n'est pas lié à la guerre d'algérie
c'est lié à tout simplement la loi est
la loi de 2008 en gros permet que sur la
période de la guerre d'algérie à l'heure
où je vous parle mais je vous aurais dit
autre chose il ya deux ans les archives
sont accessibles pourquoi je vous aurais
dit autre chose à deux ans parce que les
archives est un sujet politiquement
sensible et que l'on peut avoir des
tentations parfois du politique ou de
l'administration de modifier les choses
et donc d'alimenter de mensonges et des
fantasmes d'alimenter des fantasmes
certainement des mensonges non mais en
tout cas l'incapacité d'accéder aux
documents c'est un vrai problème nous
sommes raphaëlle branche en ce moment
témoins d'une autre guerre nous savons
évidemment qu'il faut se méfier des
comparaisons puisqu'il y en a qui
peuvent être très dangereuses surtout
quand elles paraissent trop facile mais
tout de même est ce que cette guerre
d'algérie peut avoir aujourd'hui une
quelconque résonance avec celle dont
nous sommes témoins aujourd'hui en
europe occidentale je pense que la
question de la résonance c'est la bonne
manière de le poser c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ces deux sont des échos
mois pour travailler sur la guerre
d'algérie vous répondre comme
historienne ce qui me frappe beaucoup
sais c'est qu'on va pour on prend enfin
conscience que la guerre est une bascule
dans un autre temps un rapport au temps
une temporalité différente on le sait
bien on est tous de cette manne de ce
point de vue là touché par la guerre en
ukraine parce que notre temps a basculé
on ne sait pas si demain on sera encore
là on ne serait pas si demain la pologne
sera pas envahi on est dans un état dans
un état dans un rapport à notre présent
qui a été profondément bouleversé
merci beaucoup je vous en prie va faire
beau alors où est ce qu'on peut voir
votre film allait peut-être sur arte sur
arte.tv en replay jusqu'en jusqu en août
merci beaucoup film que vous cosigné
avec raphaël le losc est en guerre pour
l'algérie guerre au pluriel merci d'être
venus jusqu'à l'os était l'invité de de
paris direct l'information
internationale et française continue sur
france 24